according to Customs and Border  Protection at tens of thousands of  migrants are headed to the U.S border  right now this happens every so often  where you'll see some huge migrant  Caravan from working its way up through  Latin America these events shouldn't be  all that shocking in that we have two  million illegal aliens come every single  year we have thousands of thousands of  people every single day across our  border but when you see these incidents  where it's thirty thousand forty  thousand uh CBP agents are now  predicting more than 40 000 migrants in  southern Mexico who will soon be at the  U.S border when you see that it's  shocking because you can at least look  at the pictures but you're getting a  tenth of that every day in the United  States so it's not it's only shocking in  that it allows us to see what is  persistently happening in the country